so I looked at your IMDB and is the
first credit writing credit the perfect
nanny with Tracy Nelson and that is the
first one yeah okay great so how is that
the one that you had from doing the
rewrite and then the producer wanted to
hire you um no I got fired off that
project
oh no yeah I that was with a producer
who I was working as an assistant in
development and then left he sold the
company I left was working then as a
reader for a little bit and then he
invited me to come back and do this
rewrite which I did and I think it did
two drafts and they hired another writer
which is fine if I mean at the time I
was sort of sad about it but it was a
great learning experience because I
didn't know what I didn't know right and
so now looking back to see where I've
grown where I'm now the last writer on
because I you know that was it was good
for me to go through that experience and
I was very grateful that he gave me the
opportunity even to do that one because
that ended up me my first credit okay so
the one that you were fired off with
maybe not giving away too much
information but did you see what it was
or was it something that was out of your
control no I just wasn't a good enough
writer to do what they needed me to do
okay so I I did improve the script and a
lot of what I put in there ended up in
the final cut but I think I just didn't
know structure well enough to be able to
fix some of the issues that they had
that they needed me to fix and so I
fixed the character stuff and then I
think they hired another writer to fix
all the structural stuff that was wrong
with it and so at that time did you see
it as structure like a structural defect
or no no I did I couldn't recognize that
at that time yes
so then once you probably were excellent
at structure then you saw that's what it
was yeah and I think it's also just over
time understanding getting to know more
what what they want when they tell you
we need this or we want this what that
means and how to incorporate that into a
screenplay
you know I we want to add edge to this
it's not edgy enough that's a very
obscure you know idea so
so hearing that when I was that early in
my career I don't think I understood how
to implement edge and now when someone
says that okay now I understand the
questions to ask so I can tell me what
they really want and I understand what
they mean by that so it's just over time
I've learned what that means so if it's
let's suppose it's a housewife that has
everything perfect and nothing's wrong
how would you incorporate some edge into
that because I'm picturing that as the
lifetime movie that I knew which was so
interesting but what edge would we add
times they might have like a dark secret
or a fetish or something in their past
that they feel ashamed of that they've
kept from their husband so something
like that the the is sort of just kind
of lurking in the background this seems
to sort of resurface and doesn't even
have to be part of the a story it can be
something that just complicates the a
story right so you know she's like let's
say your housewife they're been trying
to get pregnant she's finally gotten
pregnant and she has this ex boyfriend
who is getting out of prison and still
wants to be with her and so now he's
gonna come back and complicate her life
and that may not be the a story but it's
something that now she has to tell her
husband who this person is and bla bla
right and there's the edge and there's
edge right so there's the intrigue to
that so it's it's adding to it's just
it's it's rounding out that story right
and making people real because everybody
has things that they're not proud of or
whatever and so this is something that
you can add those and we can go even
further you know in the Lifetime movies
or TV movies with that kind of stuff so
is the aim to show sort of perfection
and then as we said before backing out
and then seeing that it's not perfect I
don't know if it's to show perfection I
think a lot of what intrigues people are
the pretenses right I think so much of
what we try to do even with Facebook is
to show everybody in the world what this
great life we have what every great you
know you don't take the picture of the
crappy ramen noodles you made last
you're so tired to cook you take it when
you're at a nice restaurant right look
as beautiful or this thing that you made
and you spent hours on we put out a life
that we want other people to see because
that's what we think they're forming
their opinions of us the irony is that
most people care more about themselves
and they care about anyone else anyway
so they're not even forming those
opinions but that's what we do our
characters are the same thing you know
our characters live lives based on what
they think they should be living right
and so that's why it's kind of fun when
you can you can flush these characters
out and give them these things in their
past or things that they're doing or
temptations or whatever you know that
cause those little things of conflicts
right and they always have to have a
great place to live and all the life
time I mean I've never seen a woman in a
lifetime movie live in a bad place that
whatever happens there's definitely an
escapism element to that as well